[Music]
It's God. It's God. It's
God. It's God.
Okay.
You're supposed to say it before you
read the Quran. Before you read the
Quran, you're supposed to say that. No.
No. I'm saying it. I feel it. You know,
you don't always do it. out your hand.
You don't need to do that before the
Quran. By the way, you need to study
Islam. Now, guys, first time I am
buying my Christian friend, a present.
Now, why did I buy him a present? I know
there's a lot of people jealous. David
Wood a he became a Christian once he
raised,000. AP come on. Put his wife He
put his wife in a hijab. The man put his
wife in a hijab. He said, "Listen, we're
making some good money here, £100,000.
You better put that hijab on." So, we
don't believe that, but I'm sure he
Christ came to him in a vision like it
did with
Paul. I even wrapped it up
myself in Pepper Pig.
I had to. Even though pork is haram, do
you eat pork? No. That's You know what?
Big up to no
for me. My name is Abra. What's your
name? Abra. I call you know. Come here.
We We ain't got to give it We ain't got
to give out him. We would have. No, we
would have. But I heard that you condone
ripping the Quran. I I said under the
right circumstances. Interesting. I
believe in no circumstances, I would
never rip up the Bible. That's fine. No
circumstances that you follow Jesus. If
somebody if if somebody rips up the
Bible and then somebody I got you. I But
if if somebody rips up the Quran in
return, would you would you blame them?
If someone rips up, if somebody rips, if
somebody rips up the Quran in response
to somebody ripping the Bible, would you
would you condone that? Two wrongs will
make a right. Allah says in the Quran,
would you blame them though? Yes. Oh,
especially if he's a Muslim. For
example, if someone not a Muslim,
someone rips up the Quran.
Sorry.
You okay? Need some water?
I got water in my bathroom.
[__] someone rips up the Quran. Bro,
you need some water.
Anyone else? You okay? Yeah. But hey,
hey, that's fine. But it's fine. Hey
guys, pray pray for Ali Daw. Man, the
Lord is going to touch him. I think
water will be enough. Keep give that to
yourself. If someone rips up the Quran
and in return somebody rips up the
Bible, he's going against the Quran
because the Quran says I know repel evil
with that which is good. So with us we
don't believe two two wrongs make a
right. I know I know now my thing is
this to you.
Yesterday we had I would have a nice
cord discussion with you because you
came to me all polite and this that but
the thing is your reality is not that.
If your reality was that bro let me be
honest with you I have a nice
civilization. That is how I am. No you
know you condone looking the Quran. I
condone I condemn anyone that rips the
Bible. Not that we have anyways. So
anyways, you are as bad as the ones that
But this is my point though. My point is
is that your Quran says do not mock
those who invoke other than Allah.
Right. Lest they will mock Allah in
return. Right. So what I'm saying is is
that the Quran warns Muslims of
provoking the people to certain actions
when they mock. Right. Exactly. So what
I'm saying is is as a Muslim if you see
that a Christian responds right in let's
say ripping the Quran or mocking
Muhammad or or Allah they respond
because because the Muslim is cursing
God or cursing Jesus cursing the Holy
Spirit. Which Muslim curses Jesus? Uh
there's Muslims like Aki X shadow AX.
There's Muslims like uh he says what? Uh
oh I I'm not going to repeat it but what
he does I'll tell you what he does. He
he has a he has a picture where he puts
Jesus on a on a cross in a clown
uniform. That's what he does. Jesus is a
prophet. I know. But exactly. That's my
point. I'm Muslims. No, we could we
can't insult Jesus cuz we But they do it
all the time. No. Again, to us if they
do it for you to insult Jesus is
prophet. Look, Ali, I know what you're
saying. But what you're saying is, no,
no, no, you're being slightly you
condemn, you condone the ripping of the
Quran. Only in context. Only as a
response to to said action. Listen, we
Muslims are the what are you going to
call it? The terrorists and we are
antichrist for some odd reason. For some
odd reason, we as Muslims, we don't read
the Bible. Yeah. You what? You guys be
stepping on the Bible all the time. What
are you talking about? You stepped on
the Bible. Look, I'm telling you, Aki X
is a is a Muslim on TikTok.
You g You ask me who. I'm giving you an
example. One second. If you don't know
him, that that's on you. But Akx, he
ripped up pages in the Bible and put him
in the toilet. Tell me any brother in
the Dawa scene who is known. What do you
mean in the da scene? Everybody on
TikTok knows him. I repeat again. I
repeat, you're not going to get me some
random guy somewhere. You ask me who?
Yes. Oh, I'm going to say Christ. Listen
to me. Has there been me hijab?
What does that what I got to do? No. No.
Has any of them ever disrespected the
Bible by ripping it? Nothing I've seen.
Nothing I've seen. That doesn't matter.
You asked me who. Let me Hold on. Let me
No. Let me answer you. Let me say it.
That's why. Let me say something. Okay.
You condone the ripping of the Quran.
Hold on a second. You should be ashamed
of yourself. Ali, you got to let me talk
too, bro. Let me finish. I'm going to
talk. Okay. You should be ashamed of
yourself. You also follow Christ. Yeah.
Jesus is love. Yeah. Love your enemies.
Yeah. Turn the other cheek. Yeah. Shame
on you all. You know why? Because we as
Muslims are the closest to you guys. We
are the closest to you guys. The Jews,
what do the Jews say? Jesus is burning
in his own feces. What do they say about
Mary? She is an adulterer. What do we
say? We renovate. We honor them. And
what do you do? Your number one public
enemy is who? Islam. Not that was faced
by you guys. Your arguments a week like
we saw yesterday. We saw your arguments
a week, bro. It's finished.
Yes. So now tell me I'm not I'm about to
respond to what you said. Respond to
what I said. Yeah. I'm responding to the
Quran. Yeah. So at first Ali Dawa, you
said who? Who? Show me anyone. And I
named you a Muslim. I gave you one by
name. And now you shifted the goalpost
to Well, okay. Well, give me somebody
from the Dawa scene that's wellnown. You
switched the goalpost to that. All you
asked for at first was a Muslim that did
did uh for example. So I'm showing you
did. But now you switched it to, oh
well, who's the popular among the
Muslims who does that? That doesn't
matter. If you got Muslims, like for
example, I deal with Muslims all the
time. I think more than what you do cuz
I do the, you know, debate every day. So
I see what Muslims do. And if I see
Muslims be disrespectful to the Holy
Spirit, disrespectful to Jesus, and it
garers a response to Christians, I have
no problem with a Christian responding
to Muslim action by even if even if it's
ripping the Q only if it's cursing God.
Okay? If you if they curse God, ripping
the Quran is on the table for them. I
won't blame them for doing that. Now,
however, I will never say or giving
encourage and I would condemn if
somebody is going around ripping Qurans
just for the sake of it with under under
no um you like for no reason. You know
what I'm saying? So, nobody should be
doing that. But if people are cursing,
if Muslims are cursing the Holy Spirit,
cursing our God, then they get what they
do. They they get what comes of them. No
problem. What's Okay. You say no
problem. Problem. Okay. Are they good
and bad Muslims? Sure. Are they good and
bad Christians? Yeah. If I was to say to
you, if I said any Muslim, that would be
silly of me. If I said that, did I say
Muslim? You said Muslim in general. If I
said Muslims in general, I'm wrong. I
said to you, of course there's Muslims
do bad and good stuff. We know
Muslims that do crazy stuff. My argument
was this. You are a person that is
following Christianity. I am someone
who's in, as you know, we do Dowist. No
one in the dowist scene has ever ripped
the Bible out. Now, let's go with
argument sake. Do you follow Christ?
Yep. Do you? I believe I do. But one
second, we'll come to Okay, we're here
right now. We're boom boom. Okay. What
would Jesus do? In what regard? Argue.
Let's go for argument sake. Muslims,
they rip the Bible. If they rip the
Bible, what would Jesus do to say that?
I don't know. Maybe. I I think actually
what Jesus would do, he would go up to
the Muslim and call him which one. This
is what he'll do. What what what Jesus
would do is he'll go to a Muslim. He'll
go to a Muslim. Yeah. He'll go up to the
Muslim and he'll call him a snake and a
viper and a hypocrite because they claim
to follow him and then they point the
finger at others while they reject who
he is and reject his words. So that's
what he'll do. Okay. So did Jesus turn
the cheek? In what in what regard? In
what context? Oh, this context of
course. Okay. Interesting. Yeah. Jesus
is not a pacifist. He teaches mercy
rather than, you know, he's not he's not
a pacifist. Listen carefully to what
he's saying. Yeah. I don't want to hear
anymore. We love you. If you slap us, we
turn the
other. He's just abregated that. I
didn't abregate nothing. Don't
misrepresent. No. No. No. So, you're
telling me
Muhammad abregated that, bro? Jesus is
walking. He sees a Muslim. We don't We
as Muslims in the public, we don't do
that. Rip up the Quran. Do what? Rip up
the Bible. Yes, you do. Okay. Which one
of the influenc There's people that do.
Which one of the Muslim influencers has
ever publicly ripped the Bible? What
does that got What does that got to do?
You're you're saying you said no Muslim
goes around and publicly ripped up the
Bible. That's what you said. Stop saying
no Muslim. Stop saying that. Which
Muslim public influencer in the Dow
scenes as a role model has ripped What
do you mean a role model? What? That's
all subjective, dude. That's all
subjective. So look, if I give you a
Muslim that does that publicly, you're
going to say, "Ah, well, he's
irrelevant." No, no, no. One thing. Can
you tell me one? A X.
Who the hell is AX? a Christ follower
somewhere around there. Come on, my
friend. There's no one there. Point it.
Now,
pointing to you, he'll call you a snake
and a viper and a hypocrite. Would Jesus
rip the Quran instead? I don't know. He
wouldn't. How do you know? You don't
know that. Now, let's come to the chase.
But today is his birthday. Okay. Can you
open the present, please? No. Not yet.
No. Come on, man. It's a present. What's
the whole point of what? What's the I
don't buy my kids toys from Hley's £30.
What is Hley? I r myself. It's an
expensive toy store. A toy store? They
said to me, "What age group are you
looking for?" I said, "A threeyear-old."
Why a three-year-old? Open it. Why not a
Open it? Six. Nah. Oh, why a
three-year-old? All right, let's see.
I like this. You said you have yourself.
No, you're a guest. You came to another.
Please give you a gift. I see.
It didn't take me 1 hour. I had to for
the homies. I had to buy a gift. I had
to wrap it myself.
What? What is I know you guys are
jealous cuz you didn't get it. You hated
it. Now we need to open it. We're not
open. Go. We open it together. One
thing. One thing, please.
Bro, why you ripping my side, man?
He's good, DJ. It's good, DJ. It's
good. It's good. It's chill. Chill. He's
touching my son. He's It's good, DJ.
It's all
right. No, no, no, no.
No, no, no. I'm going to walk. I'm going
to
walk the circle. Leave the
circle. Leave the circle. And now you
need the circle. So, why you lying? Why
did you lying? No. No. Last year I asked
him, you always claim that the Quran
found the Bible. He denied. He said I
did not make that claim. And now look,
he's claiming it. Please, please don't
touch him. Look, last year he said to
me,
someone wait please wait listen. This
guy is a lion. He's wasting our time.
I have that video is on Tik Tok
everywhere lost logic last year. I asked
him you made a claim which is the Quran
the Bible. And now he came to me. He
said I did not make that claim. And now
he's claiming it. And when I ask him to
describe you according
[Applause]
to what's in
you in
you what's
the what's the what's
the wait
listen again he said the Bible confirms
I mean the Quran
When I ask you to describe
those now a
liaros dancing dancing all of them
there you
This was show
us I didn't make a claim and now
you said I didn't make
my scared when he saw me. I didn't
make
that
video back up. Let's get some space.
Just give us some Christians. Give us
some space. You might You
[Applause]
might look Hello, guys. Can we Can we
have I invited you to this party? I
don't want to kick you guys out.
Now, yesterday we had an argument of
debate and my argument was for
contingency.
That's That's called a nerve
love. Nervous love. I don't know. He's
like He's like, "Oh no, I don't know
what's coming out now since I
realized no logic. Doesn't know his
shapes." I bought him.
Okay. I spent 30,000. Relax.
Okay.
Person number two. Second person.
Can you get the triangle out? Yeah.
Yeah. Okay.
Cuz I thought to myself, you know what?
When you talk about triangles and
squares, you have you need to have it in
front of you, sometimes it doesn't make
sense. We'll call this the Holy Spirit.
We'll come to it later.
Now,
What shape is this?
I have I have to Don't blame me. Don't
blame me. Yes. Let's go bring the shape
together. We're going to demonstrate it
now. Now the triangle. What's this?
We're about to see just how dumb this
is. Yes, you're right. We're about to
see just how dumb this is. We literally
are now. So now I'm I'm about to I'm
about to I'm about to indulge you. I'm
going indulge you. What What does that
mean? It means I'm going to entertain
you. So, no, no, I'm entertaining. Yeah,
you are entertaining. I know you're
entertaining me. That's what I'm saying.
So, when you have when you have this,
watch this. This, ladies and gentlemen,
this is a triangle, right?
This come this lad. Hold on. Let me hold
it. Oh, yeah. Hold up. But it's going to
fall out. Oh, God. Got. So, this, ladies
and gentlemen, is a square. Okay. Okay.
Okay. A square. Are the squares next to
each other? Yeah. Is this a
contradiction?
Hold. Can Now listen carefully. Can you
hold this now? Now watch how they're
going to go dead side. Hold it like
this. Now hold it like this. Can someone
hold this for me?
Can someone hold this for me? Hold this
for me now. Yesterday I made an argument
for contingency. I said there are three
types of existence. The first existence,
what? A triangle square. He's got to do
that. Stop trying to jump off the pot.
Is it a contradiction? Hold on. Hold on.
Triangle square. Now, can you have a
triangle square? Can you have a triangle
square? Is this a contradiction if
they're next to each other? Okay. Now,
if they are next to each other, how many
shapes are there? There's two. Okay. Is
that a contradiction? One second. How?
Yes or no? How many natures? How many?
One second. Jesus. Okay. One person. One
person. In. What do you mean in what? In
two. No. Two natures are in one person.
Christians, you've gone silent. Two
natures, one person. Now two. Two
natures, one person. Okay. Is this a
contradiction? This is human side. Yeah.
Is this a contradiction? Yes. Because I
said, can you have a triangle square?
This is a triangle. This is a square. If
you put them together, you have a house
that falls apart. Because I said there's
the divine nature of Jesus that you guys
believe in. Let's call him the triangle.
And there is the human nature that you
believe. There are two persons. Person
one. Two
person. One second. You're not even
quoting it right, bro. One second. Oh my
god. This is failing. Triangle. Let the
people decide. Triangle is a divine
nature. Correct.
Let's make this round. Okay. Okay. Sure.
Okay. The divine nature. Look guys,
look. Look, look. Yeah. Look. The divine
nature. You know when Coco loves, he's
in big trouble. Now, the human nature is
square. Yeah. Sure. How many persons?
One. Right. Alhamdulillah. Orthodox
Muslim. This was for you. Alhamdulillah.
Now, now this is the human nature.
Person one. This is the human nature and
the divine nature. You cannot when you
bring them together, it's a
contradiction. You cannot have a
triangle square meaning when you bring
them together you have how many shapes?
Two. He said how many persons are there?
One. So that is my argument. You can't
have the human nature and the god nature
in together because that means you have
a triangle square. A square has four
sides. A triangle has guys. How many
sides triangle have?
You can talk. How many sides? Three.
Three. How many square? Can you bring
them together? No. Why? It's an
impossibility. This is the reason why.
Look guys, he goes, you can bring them
next to each other. That's not my
argument. My argument is the following.
There's one nature that is human. There
is one nature that is God. You are a If
you say there are two two persons, then
you are committing heresy. You're right.
Yes. So, I repeat again, this is the
human nature. This is the god nature.
Yes. Can you bring them together?
Thank you. Simple question. All right.
My turn now. All right. So, Ali Dawa.
Yes. Um, I thank you for bringing the
shapes cuz we needed your help to
demonstrate just for you.
I know what you're saying. I know what
you're saying. And m fact, just really
quick, cuz you you talked about
notorianism. Do you know what that is
exactly? That they believe in two
persons. Very good. So, notorianism is
belief in two persons. Yes. Now, be
honest with me. Yes. Have I ever said
two persons? No. That's why I asked you.
Very good. All right. Thank you. Thank
you. All right. So, it's pretty clear
Ali Dawa knows that I am not saying that
there are two persons. We are saying
that there are two what? Natures. Very
good. Oh, just one second. So, natures
and persons are two different
categories. Do we agree? Okay. Yeah.
Okay. Good. So, if I say that there's
two natures, I'm not saying there's two
persons. I know. If I say there's two
natures within one person, I'm there's
two different categories. Yeah. Good.
All right. So you said that you're
talking about Yes. one nature being the
same as the other. The opposite nature
being the same as the other nature,
right? Yes. Them being together. Okay.
Are these together? Not like that. I
didn't ask that. Are these together? No.
No. Like that. I'm not talking about
that. When I put When I bring a triangle
and I bring a square and I bring it
together. How many shapes are this? This
is two shapes. Good. Is this a Wait, I I
answered all your questions. Remember my
turn. Yes. I bring them together. Are
they Are they together? Yes. Is this a
contradiction? They are two. That's not
Don't ask you. Is this a two shapes? I I
Thank you. Wait. I look I do. It's my
turn. Yes. Are you asking me? I know.
Ask me. Is this a contradiction? Don't
talk to me. You know what? I'll go
around. Sam, is this a contradiction?
Don't talk to me. Okay. So, Sam says
yes. Okay. Sam says yes. It is a
contradiction. So putting one shape and
another shape and putting it side by
side together. This ladies and gentlemen
is a contradiction according to the
Muslims. Do you agree? We human. You
said don't talk. Do you agree? No. No. I
say you got to answer me cuz Yeah.
Answer. Is this a contradiction? Yes.
Why? Let me tell you why. Okay. So
putting two shapes together is a
contradiction according to Ali Dawa and
our friend Sam. All right. So, break
down how this is a contradiction.
Can you do me a favor and try to put the
square in the triangle? Yes.
You said it's a contradiction. Put the
square in the triangle. You said it's a
contradiction.
You said Wait, can I try the triangle?
This is your choice. Let me have the
triangle. No, no. Let me have the
triangle. The triangle. Look, look,
look. It still doesn't fit. It still
doesn't fit. It still doesn't disappear.
So, now what? Now, now hold on a second,
guys. Why is the triangle not fitting in
the square? There's another square.
Because different nature. Exactly. Thank
you, my friend. Now the square.
Why isn't it working? Let me try here.
Ah, let me try the triangle. God say,
let me
seem. It's still not working. But let me
try the triangle.
Okay. My argument is the following,
guys. I have never said you can't bring
a triangle and square. It is absolute
stupidity to say this is an
impossibility. How could this be an
impossibility of contradiction? My
argument was the following. There are
three types of existence. Oh Lord have
mercy. Exactly. Can I hold this? The
Lord's going to have mercy on you, my
friend. Yeah. Now brothers, impossible
existence. Possible existence and
necessary existence. I said an
impossible existence is what? Something
that don't exist. No, no, no. Triangle
square. Can you have a triangle square
Christians? I thought so. They know.
They know you cannot have a triangle
because a triangle is three sides. A
square is four sides. He said, "But you
can bring them together." I said, "I
have no problem." Looks like a house,
but I'm destroying the house. You know
why? Because you can't have a triangle
square. I got you. Now, one second. Just
one second. This is really bad. Now, I'm
going to We'll let the people decide.
It's bad. It's good. It's medium. I want
a Well done. medium rare. How you like
your steak? No problem. Now brothers and
sisters, human nature is person. Look,
human nature is not personal. And you
have good nature. The human nature is
totally opposite. You know why? Cuz my
definition of an dependent being that's
contingent is what? It depends on
something else for survival. It can be
any other way. And it is composed of
pieces. The my definition for the
necessary independent being. It is
independent. It is not composed of
pieces. And it cannot be any other way.
Got it. That's the reason why I repeat
it again. You don't have to. Look, we
can keep the toy. It's for you. I want
to show you this. Look. Look. It's a
three-year-old. If I go to my daughter
and I say, "What is a square?" She'll
say, "Dad, it's four sides." And I say,
"What is a triangle?" Say, "Dad, three
sides." If I say to her, "What is a
triangle square?" She say, "What?" So,
I'm asking you a question. It's my turn.
Yes. I know. Thank you. Can you have a
triangle square when you admitted it is
an impossible existence? Well, let's
see. Let's see. Let's see. I got you.
All right. So, Ali Dawa, I need you to
Someone took my water. Do you need
water? It's behind the
If you go in my Okay, there you go. All
right. All right. Alidawa, instead of
you being kind to me, instead of you
being kind to me with water, condemn
those
who hold on a second. So, Alawa, watch
this. Ladies and gentlemen, watch this.
It's going to be super funny. Alidawa,
what shape is this? I'll be finding you
cuz Yeah, it is. What shape is this?
Triangle. That is a square. This is a
square. Yes. Okay. What shape is in the
square? Triangle. Wait,
[Applause]
you just told me that a triangle cannot
be in a square. But you just said that
this is a square that has a triangle in
it. Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait.
I'm a little confused.
So, wait. I just want to know. I just
want to know since this is a square and
this inside the square is a triangle. Is
this a contradiction?
Yes or no? Can you wait? Wait, wait. I
just I cuz I'm about to make my point.
Yes or no? This is a square, my friend.
There's triangle, square, star, circle.
Oh, it has multiple shapes within the
square. There multiple words. I said
little gods. Now, now quick question.
Wait, no. Is it a contradiction? Yes or
no? Wait a second. You're Christian. You
know, it's not going to help you. Is it
a contradiction? No. No. Check this out.
No. Answer. Is it a No. Look, it's a yes
or no at this point. Thank you. All
right. So, now let me continue. Let me
continue. I only wanted That's fine.
Okay, that's fine. So, it's not a
contradiction that this is a square and
within the square is a triangle. But you
tried to make this whole point that it
was a contradiction earlier. It's done
and over with. I I'm I'm glad you bought
this because this is actually the
appropriate toy that I can use to
demonstrate how dumb your argument is.
This is appropriate. This is this is a
beautiful gift. Now, to continue this
beautiful gift to continue this, let me
show you. Now, let's let's let's trade
in the categories and the and the and
the characteristics. Now, okay. Now,
talking about persons versus natures.
Christ, one person has two natures. I'm
not saying that Jesus is two persons.
That is notorianism like you said
earlier. But now when I say this, I'm
not in heresy. So stop arguing against
the heresy and argue against me.
So one person, two natures. How is it a
contradiction? I mean I I you know
sometimes they say if your enemy is
making a fool out of yourself, just let
them talk. That's why they're saying let
him talk or look Muslim brother make a
field day with this. Did you just see
that? And you know what's funny? The
Christians are cheering. They don't even
know what just happened. We just want to
respond. They didn't even realize.
That's why you know what you do? Just
like you know what? No problem. Did you
see what he said? You haven't bro please
don't cut it. Don't say the editor made
the mistake here. Please. He goes this
is a square and there is a triangle
inside. Guys, guys, he got the board. He
goes, "This is a square, four sides, and
there's a triangle inside." So that
means his argument is proven. What was
the argument? That the fact that there's
a triangle in a square. And what is
that? What is my argument? If that is
your argument, then why did you say it
is an impossible existence to have a
triangle square? No, that's that shows
you missed the argument. That's not the
argument. So once again, Impossible
existence or impossible cuz he just said
what? One second. He knows what just
happened and this is why the Christians
are gone. It shows that you missed the
argument again. Let me tell you why. No.
One second. Let me finish. Let me
finish. No, let me finish. Okay. You
came in with a chef outfit and I'm going
to cook you now. Check this out. Yeah.
He said, "Guys, check this out. Awful is
watching this. He's laughing his head
off." Now, I go to him. There are three
types of existence, guys. Impossible
existence, dependent existence, and
necessary existence. He admitted, "Can
you have a triangle square?" It isn't.
He said it was an impossible existence.
Do you know what he just did now? He
went back on his word and said no square
triangle. And the Christians went you
miss you can you could miss the entire
argument. Look look you have no listen
listen. This is the point. This is a
square, right? This is a square, right?
Yes. That's one shape, right? Yes. Is
there a triangle in the square? But I
didn't wait. Just answer. Just answer.
Is there a triangle in the square? How
many shapes is that? There's two shapes.
Is that a contradiction? No. Thank you.
So, so I didn't I didn't say that. I
didn't say Look, listen. I didn't say
that. Listen, I didn't I didn't You're
You're asking can a You're asking You're
asking Listen, your your question is can
a triangle be the square? No. That's
what No, listen to me. There you go.
There you go. You're saying can the
triangle be the square? My friend, you
don't even know how to cook anywhere.
Yeah, I know. You don't. You don't know
how to pay attention. Look, it's two sh
Look, it's two shapes. It's not a
contradiction. Why did I ask? I said
there's three types of possibilities.
Existence. What was the first one? Uh
something that doesn't exist. Exactly.
Good. So now I give you exampleist. How
wait. How is non-existence a type of
existence? Wait. That's my point now.
Oh, that's that's your point. I asked
you, can I say anywhere? Can you have a
You know, a square a square triangle or
a nervous laugh. You're telling me about
Oh, yeah. He's a master of it. Or
Orthodox Mus knows his nervous laugh
when he sees one. No. No. Yeah. Now, no
laugh when he sees me. Listen. Yeah. I
asked you. I said, "Yeah." Can you have
a triangle square? What was my answer?
It was no. Okay. What did you just
demonstrate? Now, I demonstrated that
there's two shapes. Okay. Was that my
question? No. Then why are you
demonstrating this? Because you're I'm
showing you my position. My position
listen my position. Look, if you're
saying can there be a triangle square?
Basically, I'm say there's one sh
there's one and there's no answer is no.
No. No. Pay attention, bros. For the
people in the back, can you pay
attention? Can you pay attention? No, it
can't. So, pay attention. Christian, pay
attention. Pay attention. Pay attention.
Okay. So, with your position, can there
be a a square triangle? That would be
one shape. That is a square triangle.
One shape, right? Shape. I know. That's
what I'm saying. I'm I'm demonstrating
to you. If you If you going to listen,
you're nervous now. Now you're
panicking. Now, now you're panicking
now. Now you're panicking.
That's how you do. Hey guys, support the
dollar, man. He's in panic mode. Look.
Look. This is what it is. This is This
is what it is. Ali, this is what it is.
Ali, hold on really quick. You're
getting distract you're getting
distracted. Getting distracted. Okay.
Okay. I know. Be like Jesus. Got you. So
when you say triangle square, you're
asking is there one shape that could be
both a triangle and a square at the same
time? Right. And the answer is no. My
position is is not that Jesus has one
nature that is mixed with human and
divine. My argument is my position is
that Jesus has two natures. One divine,
one human, and they're united in the
person. They don't intermingle. They're
not mixed. Just like Hold on. Let me
finish. Let me finish. Let me finish.
How many panic? Notice the panic here.
How many? Notice the panic here. Notice
the panic. Thank you. I appreciate it.
So, what you need to deal with is my
actual position. I'm not saying that
there's one nature that's mixed. I'm
saying there's two ma natures that are
united in one person. So, just like with
this, I demonstrated to you that a
square can be with a circle or a a
triangle. They can be united next to
each other, but it's not and it's not a
contradiction. Just like you acknowledge
this is a square and this is a triangle
in the square. They're united, but it's
not a contradiction. You understand? Do
you Did you get the You get the
demonstration kind of. Okay. Okay. So,
if I say that, wait. If I say there's
two natures, is that a contradiction?
Yes. Let me tell you how. If I say
there's two shapes, is that is that a
contradiction? We'll wrap this up once
and for all. Here's the uppercut.
Here is the upper cut. The upper cut.
This is triangle. We call it the divine
nature. He's preparing for the uppercut.
You know in boxing we do boxing keep the
warm up and get your guards off me.
Okay. This is divine nature. Correct
guys. Push your hands. Can we fil me
please? Coco. Can I have a Yes. Thank
you. Divine nature. This is the human
nature. Correct.
How many shapes do I have in my hand?
How many shapes? Two. Two. Two. He's
saying bring them together.
What is the shape called? It's still a
It's still a square and a triangle. Two
shapes still. You still got two shapes.
What's it say again? You still got two
shapes. Oh. Oh, but I thought there one
person.
I'm not saying there's one. I'm not
saying there's two person. Oh my gosh.
Hey, it is doing this. What? It's doing
this. What is the shape of this? What is
the shape? Oh my gosh. What is the
shape?
Thank you. Hallelujah. Everybody gets it
except you. Big man. What shape is this?
Everybody gets it except you. You guys
know I need you to get some milk. Father
is this. The human nature, the divine
divine nature when you bring them
together, what is the shape called?
Square.
A triangle square. How many shapes?
Alhamdulillah. Alhamdulillah.
Alhamdulillah.
Alhamdulillah. Thank you. Thank you. And
now I'm going to talk to you guys about
we about to talk about don't believe in
any of you we don't need them for you
don't need triangle square the triangle
means a square is triangle one second
where's the thing he's present the
square is in the triangle and there's a
staram alhamdulillah can wait can we
talk about let's talk about you don't
need no god all you need is the oneness
of god now brothers and sisters
we talked about impossible existence
You know why I did this for all of us
Muslims? He need he need to smash you
with more arguments and heresy.
Alhamdulillah. Now you you agree with
him that Jesus is Yahweh. Alhamdulillah.
Now you agree with that Jesus is Yahweh.
Brothers and sisters, let me finish now.
Do you agree? He agreed that you cannot
have an impossible existence. Good. I
need I don't agree with you. No, it's
fine. It's fine. We'll let the people
decide, man. It is fine. I impossible
existence is non-existence. That's not a
type of existence. Now, that's so
stupid. Existence. Alhamdulillah. We say
what? There is dependent things. We are
all here depending on who? On God
Almighty. Would you agree? I'm sure the
Christians will agree as well. Do we
depend on God? My Christian friends.
Yes. Do we depend on God? Thank you.
Good. Now, we say that we depend on the
independent being that is not composed
of pieces that can be any other way.
Now, what do we know about that
independent necessary being? Number one,
if the universe is dependent, it's
dependent on who? the independent
creator. I'm not going to call him Allah
for now just so you guys can open your
ears. This independent being he is the
one who created to the universe. That
means he has a will. Let me finish. He
has a will. He we know that we have
knowledge in our universe. He has to be
the all knowing. We know that there is
power in the universe. He has to be the
all powerful. We know that there are bad
things happen universe. He has to be the
all wise. So now that independent being
that we all depend on that we all depend
on. Yes. Is the one true creator that we
are calling our Christian brothers and
sisters here. I don't hate you guys. I
don't have an animosity towards you
guys. You might with me. Yes. I don't
have that with you. All I'm saying is
this that Allah says in the Quran, tell
the people of the book, can we come to
common terms between us and you that we
worship one true creator? The one that
is the all powerful. Not fully man,
fully God, fully hippo, fully man. None
of this. So my message is this guys.
I've demonstrated it here with patterns.
You know why is going to say I've showed
you guys and you've seen it for
yourself. So I call you guys to Islam.
And if you guys come to Islam and take
your shahada, we have a charity that
teaches you how to pray just like Jesus.
And now I'm going to give the final
statements to no logic because you know
why God lo means believe in one God. A
dog logic is that a dog obeys one master
and no logic is as you saw a triangle
square inside triangle. The last word is
yours, my friend. I hope you appreciate
your gift. Where you going? I'm here.
I'm here. I ignore it. I I guess we're
not going to talk about I guess. Huh?
No, sir. Um this this is where we're at.
This is where we at here, guys. So, we
saw that um that slow Dawa here doesn't
understand shapes. Um it's it's actually
ironic because he brought the perfect
gift for an illustration for what he was
missing. And so when we showed what he
was missing, he says that putting two
shapes together is a
contradiction. And he admitted that this
is a square and within it is a triangle.
I asked him if this was a contradiction.
He said no, but then he said yes later
on. I don't know. He brought the gift.
He didn't get it, but that's okay. If
we're talking about sahed, like for
example, um you said that you don't
believe in a god that depends on
anything, right? If Allah doesn't depend
on anything, my question to you is this.
If Allah wanted to, Ali dawa, could
Allah have a son if he wanted to?
I want you to talk about Let's talk
about last make. Say whatever you like.
So now he don't want to do it. He had
all this energy for the hypothatic
union. But when it talks about, he's
ready to go. Just one statement and
you're done. Huh? You're done. Huh?
Hallelujah. And tonight, Hallelujah.
Ali, you don't want to talk about it.
You're done now. And where's You're done
now. Where's your Where's your body god?
You can Are you Are you done? Are you
done? All right, he's done. If you want
to come in, you come in. You know, it's
been emotional. So, just to be clear,
Alhamdulillah. To show you that you Hold
on. Let me You said I get the last
statement. You said I You said I get the
last statement. Yeah. So, you said that
you don't you don't believe in a
dependent God. You can't answer the
question on whether Allah could have a
son or not if you wanted to. Showing
that you're afraid to get into the
discussion of but you're ready to press
the hypoatic union something that you do
not understand fundamentally. But when
we ask simple questions about Allah,
they don't want to talk about him. Why
don't they want to talk about Is this
your camera? Why don't y'all want to
talk about Allah? Why don't y'all want
to talk about I need I need a mic. I
need a Thank you. Thank you. Why don't
you guys want to talk about sahed? Can
you guys Muslims in the comment section?
Could Allah have a son if he wanted to?
You tell them. And if he does, you tell
them. Would he need help to do it? You
tell them. Because according to chapter
6 in the Quran, Allah says, you tell
them. How can I have a son? Yes. When I
have no mates.
So it looks like to me you believe in a
God that's dependent.
He could he could have a son. Oh no. But
he
would don't do that again. Christian,
don't do that again. You're hurting me.
In order for In order for Allah to have
a son, he needs help to do it. So by
definition, your God is dependent.
Allelujah. Alhamdulillah Yeshua. Leave
Islam.
Leave Islam. Leave Islam. Trinity is the
only way that you can know the true God.
We can come to common ground. Know the
true God. The Father, the Son, and the
Holy Spirit. That's the true God. Leave
Islam. This is Bos. All right. Make sure
Make sure this is uploaded. Oh, it won't
be uploaded. Is And that gift, I'll pay
£30 in the back. Take the bag. Take the
bag. Are you going to throw it away?
You're going to throw it away. Now, give
it to me. Give it to me. I'll give I'll
give it I'll give it to my daughter.
She'll be like, "Dad, that's a triangle.
That's a square." And then she's going
to say, "Yeah, Dad, that's not a
contradiction."
Dad, dad, that's not a contradiction.
Dad, that's an impossible existence.
Somebody believes together. Dad, that's
an impossible existence, isn't it?
the
takes debate the piano. Huh? Are you
going to debate? Of course. What's He's
already I've already debated him. No. If
he if he wants he can come to my channel
and we can talk as long as you're
running away. Tell Tell him to come to
my channel. All right. I'm live Monday,
Wednesday, Friday. Tell him come. Okay.
Wait a second. Where's Where's your
camera? Right here. Nah, I don't trust
you. Where's our camera? Right here.
Tell Orthodox Muslim if he wants to talk
to me, he can come talk to me. Smash
this guy again. Do it. Do it. Come tell
us how Jesus is Yahweh in a sense.
All right. Do it again.
All right. Wrap up. Wrap up. Wrap up.
So, man, beautiful day. It's all good.
We know you. It's all good, man. Man,
God is good today, isn't he? God is
good. Who who would have thought that
Ali Dabble would bring the perfect
gift? Who would have thought he brought
the perfect gift, had a shape within a
shape, but at first he didn't understand
how a shape can be united with another
shape. He didn't understand that until
he he saw the gift,
right? And he took the gift back. It's
okay. He he didn't want me to throw it
away. He didn't want me to throw it
away. Wait, are you a chef? Oh, yeah.
Chef, baby. Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. Yeah, we
made we made hal hal ali dawa. So this
so this is where we at guys. The
hypoatic union. Very simple. Now we know
that we're dealing with the carnal mind,
right? We're dealing with people who
don't want to understand. They don't
have the spirit. So they can't
understand even if they tried. And so
what they do is is they come, they act
like they have an argument, but the
whole time they're not arguing against
us. They're not arguing against us. They
arguing against heretics and oneness
folks and historians. I'm a
Christian is God. I believe he's also
man. So two natures united in the
person. Right? Pretty pretty simple,
right? 2,000 years of church history. So
I'm not we don't believe Do we believe
as Christians that the divine nature is
the human nature? No. Do we believe as
Christians that the human nature is the
divine nature? No. Do we believe that
they mix? No. Do we believe they
intertwine? No. So why are they coming
to us like we do?
I need to find We need one Muslim. And
for all of you guys watching, come and
debate us as Christians. Come debate
what we actually believe. And then let's
see if you actually have arguments. Come
debate our actual position and stop
debating straw man arguments. Arguments
that we don't even make. And that's what
we saw. a cold case of a straw man
argument right in his face in an
impossible existence according to Ali
Daw's words. So with that being said,
one second. So and with that being said,
we talked about the about the hypothatic
union. He didn't want to talk about
though. Why do he want to talk about? He
said he doesn't he doesn't believe in a
dependent God. But if Allah says, "How
can I have a son when I don't have a
mate?" What does Allah need in order to
have a son? Oh, he's dependent. He's
dependent. And so, the God of Islam is
dependent. They got two creators, Jesus
and Allah, and others. Allah is just the
best. And uh, you know, bye-bye. You
know what I'm saying? There it is. Thank
y'all for coming, man. I appreciate
y'all, man.
It's God.
is God the